hey y'all it's Betsy with happily ever
after Etc and welcome back to another
Garden project so today I'm going to be
working on my drip irrigation system I
have a whole series of uh videos showing
you how to install a drip system from
adding it to your faucet putting it
through your garden beds and even using
it to water your pots but while drip
irrigation is fabulous for watering when
you're gone or even while you're home
you can set it up on a timer it will
automatically water every single plant
on your property just like mine does you
might be able to hear mine actually
because all of my pots are currently
running on my porch my window boxes my
stock tank Garden around the side which
is currently a beautiful butterfly
garden
it does need to be looked at sometimes
so today we are going to be
troubleshooting a few of the most common
problems that you can get with your drip
irrigation so first one is clog strip
irrigation once you've installed your
drip I like to come out at least once a
day if not every couple days and just
look at the Garden first of all it's fun
to watch and see things grow and Bloom
and if we're not out here enjoying our
Gardens what's the point of having them
but while you're enjoying your garden
you may also start to notice problems
before they get so big that you can't
fix them so our first problem are these
two pots you may have noticed like I did
but this one is big and beautiful and
blooming and bushy and that this one's
not bad but it is a little far behind so
for a couple days I just thought well
this one must be getting more sun he's a
happier pot
then I started looking into why else
besides Sun might this one be a little
behind and take a look
the drip irrigation is not running in
this pot
now the drip for this these two pots
comes up from the wall under my window
boxes around and into both of these pots
so it hits this pot first and this pot
second so the fact that this pot is
running means water is running past this
pot and just not into the pot now I
plugged these last year so sometimes you
do need to replace emitters on a yearly
basis even if your most of your tubing
and uh connectors are going to last you
quite a while so I took a look and short
enough
I see water
coming out of the back of this tube but
not into the actual emitters of this so
what I'm going to do
is we're going to cut this off at the
base here and we're going to see if
water is coming out of it if it is all
we need to do is add new emitters around
the base
it's making a funny noise I was just
checking it's fine
I hope can you guys hear the kids
playing behind me
if it is not coming out of my black
quarter inch tube here then we will have
to just keep following it further back
along the drip line until we come to the
source of the problem so first most
common issue with your drip irrigation
is something getting plugged and having
to replace it the easiest way to do that
is to clip out to the offending emitters
and add in a new one which is why drip
irrigation is so much nicer than a
soaker hose or a regular hose instead of
having to replace the entire hose or
splice it together with a metal
connector which will eventually be a
weak spot we can slice in a new piece of
tubing and it is not a weak spot it is
just a continuation of the old system so
let me bring y'all in and show you this
and then we will move on to fixing our
second problem
all right so moment of truth let's go
ahead
and you can see
that there is water coming out right
here so I'm going to guess
that when we cut this there will be
water coming out of the black tube
hardly one-handed there we go yep
sorry y'all I'm a mess so there is
there's water coming out of this tube
so that means
that
I set this to turn off in a minute so it
should be winding down so that means
that somewhere
after the end of this black tube is the
problem so instead of troubleshooting
all three of the emitters in this pot we
are simply going to remove this ring and
add a new one
all right let's go ahead and we're just
going to cut it right here
take this
this tube out
and now we are going to measure a new
piece
[Music]
ta-da
put in a little emitter
and add it into our pot
and the black tubing
and connect the circuit
perfect
now because this was only two or three
small emitters I figured it was easier
just to cut out all three of them and
replace all three emitters with new
tubing if this was a block
and one of my larger drip tubes say in
my garden bed I would want to find the
emitter that was not working cut that
emitter out and replace just that
section of tube with a new section
for now
we will consider this guy fixed I'm
going to go ahead and water him and then
I will keep watching them over the next
couple days if he continues to struggle
we can always add an extra emitter to
this pot he might need to want more
water
than his friend
and that's okay too
some plants like these impatients need a
little more water when these were
struggling I came in using a length of
black tubing and I added an extra
sprinkler head emitter
to these three M patients now instead of
wilting they are filling in this one's
almost tripled in size since we planted
it and they are doing fabulously so
individual water
one of the best parts of a drip system
so if our little petunia doesn't perk
back up we will give him his very own
large emitter these are great because
they are a 1 to 10 gallon ratio meaning
if I turn it smaller they get less water
if I turn it bigger they get more water
and we can really customize
how much water they get
let's go ahead head on to the porch for
our next issue all right y'all so my SAT
lavender plant it's on The Struggle Bus
he is wilting really hard and I noticed
a few days ago that he was so
waterlogged he could hardly handle it so
we're going to go ahead and put some
drainage holes in the bottom of this pot
I thought he had some but I actually uh
was wrong he has none this guy does he's
draining just fine and there is space
underneath where water is getting out
but this guy is just
just literally waterlogged and so
yeah we're gonna go ahead and all I'm
gonna do is kind of bring him to the
edge
and I'm going to try drilling a whole a
few spaces in the bottom of this box
wish me luck
I'm sure there are
eight million better ways to do this but
this is the one I'm doing
[Music]
there we go
is one
honestly I'm going to go ahead and let
this drain completely as much as it can
and then I will drill two more holes on
the other two sides
hopefully this guy will be much happier
when he's not drowning
let's go ahead and just leave this guy
and we'll be back
[Music]
all right that is three new drain holes
for our lavender you can tell that he is
really wilting even more than yesterday
at the beginning of this video I was
drilling the holes in the bottom of this
guy and he took so long to drain that we
lost the light so it is now the second
day but we've got three drain holes in
the bottom and hopefully he will be
fixed before you know it but that is the
second problem that I often find with
drip irrigation if it is not too little
water it's too much water so if your
plant is not is wilting but you really
can see
this guy's starting to have the same
problem water sitting on top of the
surface and not draining down through
then the problem is probably too much
water
you can solve this a couple of different
ways in a pot like this one you can
drill some drainage holes so I will
probably do some for this guy
just in a second thought he had some
maybe he doesn't have some either
I think I would check these things
don't do as I say not as I do
in the landscape if you are over
watering with say an emitter of some
kind you can always remove a few
emitters near that plant or turn down
the emitters if you're using a
adjustable emitter
some plants especially once they're
established are very drought tolerant
and need a lot less water in years two
three four five than they did in their
first year so they start wilting and the
problem is not not enough water problem
might be too much water
cut some out and see if that helps
we're gonna go ahead head up The Path
over near our brand new Popstar hydranda
and work on the third issue
okay so the third issue I am always
having with my drip system is adding
drip to a new location
if like me you already used three or
four different zones off your front
faucet two zones off your back closet
you may not want to add a new Zone a new
filter a new project for every single
area in your garden we're at my front
garden I have one Zone on the left of my
front door one on the right
this area around my tree is a third Zone
and my fourth zone is all of the pots on
my porch the two white pots that we just
did by my bid and all of my window boxes
so when you're running a drip system you
want to keep the area you're doing
fairly concise the further you run your
drip tube the harder it's going to be to
get the water all the way to the end
anytime you can run a closed circuit the
easier the water will have from going
from point A to point B instead of going
all the way along one line and having to
reach the end it can go down two lines
meet in the middle and the constant
pressure will keep the water going so
when I added these little plants to the
right of my oak tree garden bed I went
ahead and I trenched right here a line
through the rocks and I brought my water
over to these four plants in doing so I
have reached the end of a line so the
water comes from my faucet all the way
along my house
trenched underneath to my garden bed I
did trench it in two places so it comes
all the way across the front of my house
splits and goes in two places and comes
in at the top and bottom of this garden
bed to completely cover the entire guard
event at the moment it's only going from
right down here
across
and then it hits one two three four
plants I still want to add one more
planter to the top of this little
grouping if you haven't watched the
video for these plants I am trying to
create just a little hedge right here
that will stop your eye fill in with big
plants these get six by six ten by four
these are big plants that will create a
hedge but that also means big plants
they need lots of water so right now
instead of continuing to get all my
water from this one spot all the way
over and instead of putting four plants
on a whole new drip system I'm going to
go ahead I'm going to tap in right here
I'm going to trench across and I'm going
to make this another circuit so that the
water can come from this circuit all the
way around with even pressure or come
across meet in the middle and that will
help my plants get more water use easily
without the system working so hard and
that is my third tip when you are adding
a new system to an existing system or a
pot where you didn't have a pot before
instead of creating a whole new system
and you have to work with what you have
work smarter not harder
and you can only put in one drip line
goes on the top
I don't know why I trenched out the
bottom of the hill going uphill is
always hard
so we're gonna go ahead I'm going to
move some rocks I'm going to trench
across and we will lay black quarter
inch tubing from our system all the way
across and then we will connect in good
job biddy to the tubing by our brand new
pop star hydrangea
then we will have water for days
well it is so humid out here today
[Music]
all right so we've got our trench dug
and now
we've used our little tool here to pop a
hole in the large half inch drip tube
and we're going to pop our quarter inch
drip tube right into that hole
ta-da connecting the two pieces
we've trenched underneath my edging
now we're going to lay the quarter inch
tube all the way down where we will
connect it to the pop star
and fill in the trench
and as much as I want all of my drip
tubes covered by dirt eventually I do
leave the ones with emitters exposed at
least for a little bit until I'm sure
that they are working all the plants
aren't getting enough water and that
I've added emitters or New tubes like
this
everywhere they need to go
now we're gonna have to work a little
faster because uh this water just turned
on
let's go ahead and get it connected and
then we will get it buried
let's go start coming out in this box
there we go yep
now all we need to do here is we can
we should be able to yeah cinch it
at least for now
all right
sometimes
have really good plans
foreign
[Music]
all right so I've got this guy trenched
in all the way over here my very last
step will be to connect it to the
existing drip
so
[Music]
right over here
I have a drip tube with a two gallon
drip emitter
we are going to Simply cut into that
splice this guy in
let's go ahead and add in a tea
we'll add this section right back to the
other part we cut and our new piece will
attach right here
thank you
I did have to turn the water off for
this or else
we'd be getting one
that's all right
turn it back on in a second
I am using landscape staples to kind of
hold the the drip tubing down in place
so that it doesn't get all moved around
but for the most part the dirt in these
areas will hold it in place
and since this is a walking area not a
driving area
it'll be fine
got our tube
and connect it
all right so now I have my two gallon
emitter going right to the root ball
of my plant
I've got my tea that is going to lead
right in to the drip tube for my other
plants you can see the emitters there
at the base of the Rose of Sharon
and we will simply cover over
the strip tube so that it is not showing
and we're good to go
like we were never here
and there it is my top three tips for
fixing problems with your drip
irrigation you are troubleshooting make
sure you have eyes on your system every
day watch your plants listen to what
they need so they have too little water
too much or do you need to add a bit
more irrigation a few more emitters to
have your system work easier and your
plants get the amount of water they need
I hope this helped you good luck in your
garden I will see you in the next video
you want to go back to the beginning and
check out how I installed my drip system
click here
bye y'all